[Music]
it is known that in Game of Thrones all
men must die but even on the show that's
renowned for some of the bloodiest most
shocking deaths on TV from the red
wedding to the massacre at the great
Sept of Baelor
apparently some things are still just
too terrible to be seen
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'll be revealing
brutal game of Thrones deaths that ended
up censored or cut from the epic fantasy
series and my Game of Thrones Funko pop
giveaway is running on this video too so
for a chance to win be sure to subscribe
to my channel and leave a comment with
your thoughts about the show quick
warning spoilers ahead if you're not
caught up with Game of Thrones given
Ramsay Bolton's pond Shawn for hunting
down humans with his hounds his death at
the paws of his own pups in season 6 was
a fitting end to his a rhythmically
sadistic story but the Bolton boy's
death by dog in episode 9 battle of the
bastards
was initially going to be much gorya
than it ended up in the actual episode
apart from the hounds first bites to
Ramsay's face and a shot of his bloody
hand much of Ramsay's demise plays out
off screen with the camera focusing on
Sansa's face as we hear the grisly sound
of her tormentor dying however according
to an interview and variety with visual
effects supervisor Matt Krantz a
computer-generated jaw was created for
Ramsay which was then animated to show
the flesh being ripped from his face in
the end though those effects were deemed
too grisly and were cut but that change
also had an interesting effect on the
overall scene because if Ramsay's
on-screen fate had been more graphic I
think we would have lost some of the
emphasis on Sansa and how her character
has been changed by her traumatic
experiences which was a crucial part of
the scene that we see in how she reacts
to her persecutor finally getting his
comeuppance in Game of Thrones brutal
deaths come to many men both bad and
good and season six gave us a
heartbreaking scene in the episode the
door where Hodor sacrificed himself to
save bran and mirror in a time leap
scene which also revealed the origin of
Hodos name the gentle giant held the
door helping bran and mirror to escape
the army of the Dead that had invaded
the cave of the three-eyed Raven Hodor
used all his strength to keep the whites
in the cave though we do see them begin
to break through and claw at him so
while we don't actually see Hodor
on the screen it's highly unlikely he
survived unless he was turned into white
himself originally however the episode's
director Jack bender did want to show ho
doors brutal death on screen in an
interview with observer com bender
explained that what the Dead would be
doing to Hodor would be ripping his
clothes off once they got through that
door they would be ripping his flesh off
and if the dead can go through wood
they're going to be tearing Hodor apart
showrunners Benioff and vice though
suggested that showing Hodor died in
that way would be too horrific and
therefore the audience might not fully
feel the loss of the character in the
end bender toned down the horror of the
scene including just the right amount of
scary so that we see Hodor surrounded
and engulfed by skeletal arms and long
fingers that seems like a good choice as
the scene was already distressing enough
as it took away a fan favorite just as
we discovered the truth about his origin
Cersei Lannister is certainly not a
character you want to cross if you'd
like to continue living and septa unella
found that out to her own cost in the
final episode of season 6 and boy did
Cersei relish the opportunity to turn
the tables on the woman who'd led her on
her walk of shame
yes Cersei really dragged out in Ellis
fate starting off with a bit of wine
boarding followed by a monologue to ram
home the fact that she fully understood
the power tripping ella had enjoyed
while mistreating her and as the door
closed on an Ellis cell we were left
with the sound of the septa screams as
gregor clegane began Circe's long and
painful revenge but disturbing as the
thought and sound of sabda annales fate
was lena headey told aw that the scene
we saw in the show was just the tame
version and it was actually meant to be
worse but in the end they couldn't do it
Game of Thrones loved to give us a good
old kick in the gut by killing off in
horrific ways characters we've been
rooting for and it was another fan
favorite Oberyn Martell who suffered
perhaps one of the goriest deaths on the
show so far it was such a cruel moment
when over and after almost getting
revenge for the rape and murder of his
sister Elia and her children was tripped
up by the mountain who proceeded to use
his thumbs to poke out oberyn's eyes and
crush his head as appalling as the final
version we saw in the series was the
showrunners actually cursed a
significant amount of gore from that see
according to actor Ben Crompton who
plays dollar uh said there was an editor
the scene that showed the mound him
basically pull apart all of Oberyn face
in full graphic detail in the scene we
see in the show the camera cuts to a
shot of the mountain just after he says
that I smashed her head in like this and
we hear the sound of oberyn's head
imploding I think many fans are probably
relieved that they didn't get to see the
even more shocking edit as a combination
of seeing oberyn's eyes gouged out
combined with a crunching sound that
follows was more than enough hilarious
and took revenge on the Lannisters for
oberyn's death a season later when she
poisoned miss Ella with a fatal kiss on
the lips
just before the young princess left
Dorne to travel back to King's Landing
with Jamie in an interviewer MCM comic
con Nell tiger free who was recast as
Miss Ella in season 5 revealed that a
much bloodier version of her death was
initially planned free explained that
she was given mashed up bananas with
fake blood and her brains were supposed
to be all over the ship it seems
unlikely the poison would have directly
caused miss saliz brains to spill out
but it's possible it would have caused
her to fall and split open her head in
the end though the producers decided
against that more gruesome death as they
wanted miss saliz death to reflect her
sweet character we've seen this season
how crucial Danny's dragons are to her
attempts at taking the Iron Throne but
back in season two she almost lost them
in the city of Qarth
in the sixth episode of that season she
returned to her quarters in the city to
find her gods massacred her handmaid an
eerie dead and her young dragon stolen
we discover later that Danny's other
hand made and Doria conspired to betray
her and there's a deleted scene in the
extras for season 2 it shows that it was
Doria herself who treacherously killed
Eyrie in an interview with winter is
coming actress Amrita Acharya who played
Eyrie
explained that in order to make her
death look realistic she was actually
strangled a bit during filming which
left her with huge bruises on her neck
the following day I'm guessing what
hurts even more than shooting her death
scene though was finding out after all
that this had actually been given the
chop from the final show another death
we never got to see on screen was when
Brienne of Tarth executors Stannis
Baratheon in the season 5 finale
however originally there was an extended
version of this see
in the script the scene we did see was
relatively short and simple with Brienne
finding Stannis after his army has been
decimated by the Bolton's she sentences
him to die but gives him a chance for
some last words in the episode which
aired Stannis replies in typical Stannis
fashion go on do your duty but it's just
before this line that the original
script included a small redemptive
moment for the man who believed he was a
rightful king of Westeros and the
extended scene Stannis shares that he
doesn't really believe in the afterlife
even though he'd converted to the
religion of the Lord of Light under the
influence of Melisandre he also
confesses that he's sorry for what he
did to his brother Renly and struggles
with emotion as he thinks of his
daughter Shireen who burned alive in the
previous episode this final moment would
have been a very rare display of emotion
and regret for Stannis and although
there were hints in the show that he'd
been shaken by his sacrifice of Shireen
this could have been an interesting
addition to Stannis his death scene
showing another side of his character in
the end it's not clear why the
showrunners cut the moment from the
episode but it's likely they felt the
final cut was more true to Stannis his
stoic unflinching character in fact
deleted death scenes go all the way back
to the pilot where we would have seen
the death of Jon Arryn remember it was
Jon Arryn's death by poison which kicked
off the whole chain of events in the
series when Catelyn Stark received a
letter from her sister Lisa who was also
John's wife saying that the Lannisters
had murdered her husband who then handed
the king and that they were now
conspiring against King Robert Baratheon
Jon standing the actor who played Aaron
revealed in an interview that he filmed
a scene which began with him on his
deathbed dying from poisoning and
continued with him crawling across the
room to try to write a message but when
he reached for the ink it came crashing
down on him Lena Headey Cersei then
entered the room and stamped on his
fingers before he could write anything
after which he finally succumbed to the
poison standings are the scene where his
corpse lay in state in the red cape did
however make it into the first episode
and incredibly the actor has said he
actually receives fan mail for that tiny
motionless non-speaking role I suspect
this death scene was cut because it
would have implied that Cersei
definitely knew about Jon Arryn
suspicions about her incestuous
relationship with her brother and so she
had
killed is said it's a much more
interesting and mysterious set up for
the series to leave the exact reasons
for John Aaron's death uncertain the
deleted scene would also have made
Cersei into more a stereotyped evil
villain too early in the show
Gareth Rose loves to play with ambiguity
and teasers over a long period and let's
not forget the show didn't reveal until
season four that it was Lysa who
actually poisoned her own husband okay
so what do you think about those
censored and deleted death scenes and of
all the characters we've lost over the
seasons who do you think has had the
best death so far remember to subscribe
as well as comment for a chance to win
an awesome game of Thrones Funko pop
I'll announce the winner on an upcoming
video so turn on your notifications to
catch all my new videos if you enjoyed
this I really appreciate a thumbs up and
do check out other videos you might like
right here thanks for watching and see
you next time
you big a movie lovers